tom brady will have
a new weapon at his disposal antonio
brown officially part of the team here's
tom brady explaining why he wanted to
help antonio brown get his life turned
around and get back on the football
field
watched him for a long time i've i've
seen him as a player and then gotten to
know him as a person and
you know again i think
you know i really enjoy the sport i
enjoy playing football obviously but
relationships are very important to me
and i think
if you ask all my teammates over the
years
you know more so than throwing touchdown
passes or winning games the
relationships
and what we build together and how you
get to know people is what makes
football to me so meaningful in my life
um
you know all the guys that i've played
with over the years you just have a
strong connection with and you want to
see everyone achieve their best and i
think
um
you know you when you see people
when you see people achieve things and
they put their
effort into certain things and it pays
off and it's really rewarded
um you know there's just
you know that's i think what life's
about and i've had a lot of people that
have helped me over the years had a lot
of people that
have
inspired me to do better to want to work
harder
that have helped me in the right
position to be successful and
that's all i try to be to my teammates i
try to do my best every day to make
myself available to them
however i can help them mentally
however i can help them emotionally
i just want to see people enjoy what
they're doing enjoy their job show up do
a great job and ultimately our goal for
all of us is to win football games
look that's great i love that that's the
right way for tom brady or any
quarterback to be that's leadership
but i'm sorry if antonio brown is the
last guy on the roster at the receiver
position if he isn't good enough to help
tom brady pursue and achieve super bowl
victory number seven he's not living at
tom brady's house tom brady isn't taking
all this time to help get him pointed on
the straight and narrow and keep him on
the straight and arrow sharing we talked
about this earlier down pfd live peter
king and i one of the reasons he's given
antonio brown a room at derek jeter's
mansion is to keep antonio brown out of
trouble
so it's great that he says all the right
things but he's not doing this unless
he believes
antonio brown helps him achieve the goal
of putting ring number seven on the
middle finger of his right hand and
flashing it at bill belichick
you mean tyler johnson's not living at
the derrick jeter mansion too i thought
it was all for a secret because i
thought this was a brady bunch thing uh
yeah you're exactly right mike if abe
wasn't helping tom get what he wants he
wouldn't be there you remember way back
when when the cowboys signed pac-man
jones and jerry jones hired the
bodyguard to follow pac-man jones around
all the time well that's tom brady's job
now is to keep a.b out of trouble and by
living in his house i'm sure that will
happen and he and gisele can can keep a
b on the straight and narrow and keep
him thinking about football and it does
get him thinking about football all
night i'm sure they discuss it all night
long before they go to bed so you know
it's a great thing for him and a great
thing for tom brady and are they going
to have that instant connection that
they had in the one game they played in
new england we're going to find that out
very quickly i think
and i also think about the last time we
saw antonio brown with the steelers
it was against the saints
it was 14 catches on 15 targets for 185
yards and two touchdowns it was antonio
brown doing everything he could in that
game that the saints ultimately won
31-28 because juju smith schuster had a
key fumble two days later the steelers
named juju smith schuster the team mvp
for 2018. antonio brown
throws a tantrum throws the football at
ben roethlisberger as reports and legend
has it storms out and that's that for
antonio brown in pittsburgh so enter the
new orleans saints where we see antonio
brown with the first time he's had
more than just
slap it together and get on the field he
was with the patriots for a week when he
had that performance with tom brady that
included a touchdown catch against the
miami dolphins in a blowout win
in miami week two of the 2019 season and
i continue to believe sharing
and they're never going to admit it
maybe someday some evidence will come
out i don't know maybe antonio brown
will slip up and say something at some
point i continue to believe and i'm not
saying anybody did anything wrong here
the antonio brown and tom brady were
working together long before antonio
brown signed with the buccaneers i
believe antonio brown had the playbook i
wouldn't be surprised if antonio brown
had been living
with tom brady at derek jeter's mansion
for a lot longer than the last week or
two i think this was all something that
tom brady wanted from the moment he got
to tampa bay it was something he wanted
before he got to tampa bay i think it
was scott zolak who does play by not
play by play but keller commentary for
the patriots radio network who said
within the past week or so that brady
went to see antonio brown super bowl
week in florida and said hey if i leave
i want you with me so
that this is something that hasn't just
been slapped together and i think he's
going to be on the field a lot
i think he's going to have the ball
thrown his way a lot we had a graphic
earlier today we still may have it now
that shows the number of times brown was
targeted in light of his total snaps in
that game when the patriots played the
dolphins he got the ball thrown his way
a lot given the number of times he was
on the field i think he'll be on the
field more than 30 snaps and i think the
ball is going to come his way because
tom brady wants to show everyone he was
right to go out on a limb for antonio
brown and antonio brown's going to want
to prove that tom brady was right to
trust himse
yeah mike and tom brady and mike evans
for whatever reason just haven't found
that chemistry that connection yet and
you remember the play that peyton
manning broke down what was it a couple
weeks ago saying troy aikman called it a
great pass by uh tom brady to rob
gronkowski and peyton manning said not
so fast that pass actually wasn't
intended for rob gronkowski i think it
was intended for mike evans but mike
evans didn't catch on to what brady was
doing so they just have not found that
connection and i think brady and a.b
already have that connection they found
it and i think it's going to be like you
said it's going to be immediate that
they're going to come back and have that
connection and i do think he's going to
target him a lot because like rob
gronkowski he trusts him unlike rob
gronkowski we know that ab can still
play or we think he can still play we've
seen him one time
since the 2018 season and that was in
that week two game but we think he can
still play and he could say still play
really really well unlike gronkowski and
so i like you think we're gonna see a
lot of a b on sunday and i sure hope
michael thomas plays he you talked about
a b success against the saints
michael thomas has had his greatest
success against the buccaneers and i
want to see those two guys go at it head
to head i know they're not on the field
at the same time but i think it would be
so much fun to compare those two guys as
they go out there each time on offense
and thomas did not do much in the week
one win by the saints over the
buccaneers and then it was kind of
garbage time down near the goal line
where the saints had a lead
the the clock was was winding toward
zero in the fourth quarter
latavius murray rolled up on mike evans
and or michael thomas excuse me and
caused that ankle injury that that
initially knocked him out for weeks and
then the hamstring was a problem and he
got in trouble with the team along the
way and the sooner he's back on the
field and the sooner he's producing like
he did last year the better off the
saints are going to be also for the
buccaneers chris godwin expected to play
he had finger surgery missed the week
eight game
but is expected to play
bruce erin's the head coach of the team
said that the infection there was no
infection that they they're comfortable
going forward and he's expected to play
despite having finger surgery within the
past couple of weeks so
evans godwin a b
rob gronkowski scotty miller they got
plenty of weapons and oh they have
ronald jones and leonard fernat too so
if you spread out
the
if you put four guys uh wide even if rob
gronkowski is one of them and he's in
the slot
uh and they and the defense spreads out
to try to counter it you can just run
the ball right up the middle and there
may be nobody there to tackle fournette
or jones if they bust through the front
uh the front wall of the new orleans
defense so
look i hope this is a high scoring game
i hope it's an exciting game and i hope
it goes down to the wire because i feel
like we we need that right now after
everything we've gone through this week
i think we all deserve a great sunday
night football game between a couple of
quarterbacks with a combined age of 84
which is almost old enough to run for
president in this country right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports